we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
will the trump fbi raid get more
republicans voting in november that's
the question this viewer asks
hey david angie in wisconsin just
finished voting in our primary and i
realized after last night's raid on
mar-a-lago
i wonder if this is going to bring out a
lot more republicans than normal
which is not good for wisconsin because
we have our governor's race
and senate race where i'd like to see
ron johnson go
yeah this is a completely reasonable
question and during our live stream
yesterday of the fbi raid of donald
trump's mar-a-lago house and toilet and
safe and everything one of the things
that i was saying was
is it possible that republicans will be
so in the magats mostly will be will
they be so infuriated by the raid that
now all of a sudden they will be
revitalized and inspired to vote in
november it's absolutely possible at the
same time
would that be a reason for a law
enforcement
agency
not to do what the evidence says they
have to do of course not you have to do
what the evidence says and if at this
point there's probable cause to say we
believe that there is evidence of a
crime at mar-a-lago
and it could be in trump's personal
quarters
it could be in his safe then you have to
follow that and then deal with the
repercussions as they come we i i don't
want the fbi you know one of the
problems with the fbi in the past that
we've talked about is
they take actions that seem to go above
and beyond like for example james
comey's second press conference about
hillary clinton which
arguably lost her the election in 2016.
was that a necessary press conference no
they did an investigation there was
already a press conference why do a
second one
here i don't want the fbi saying well
maybe because it'll hurt no if there's
probable cause and you have the evidence
and a judge signs off on it and you've
got all the eyes dotted and t's crossed
then you have to do what the evidence
says
and we will deal with the political
repercussions we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today we're going to talk
about the new funding for the irs and
the reconciliation bill and what that
might lead to
we will talk about a town dissolving its
police department after a police officer
sent a racist text and we will talk
about ron desantis trying to suspend a
prosecutor and how the prosecutor is
reacting all of those stories are on
today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com become a member that's
our primary funding source for this
program and you will get instant access
to the bonus show we will see you on the
bonus show in mere moments